هنا شمال سوريا حدود طويله مع تركيا تمتد
الى اكثر من 900 كم هذه الرقعه الواقعه في
الجزء الغربي طرد منها نظام الاسد بين
عامي 2012 و 2015 يعيش فيها اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين سوري 90% منهم تحت خط الفقر بحسب
بيانات فريق منسق لاستجابه انحسرت
المواجهات العسكريه في سوريا الى حد كبير
في السنوات الاخيره الماضيه لكن حربا من
نوع اخر تدور راحها حتى اليوم في هذه
المساحه حرب التجويع جماعه بشار الاسد
في البرغل فلماذا يهدد الجوع هؤلاء السكان
بوجود حدود طويله مع دوله المجاوره على
طول هذا الخط الطويل يوجد 13 معبرا اغلق
بعضها بعد عامي 2011 بسبب الحرب تسيطر
المعارضه اليوم على سته معابر هي راس
العين وتلو ابيض وباب السلام والراعي
وجرابلس وباب الهوى المعبر الاخير هو
الوحيد الذي يسمح باستخدامه لدخول
المساعدات الدوليه العابره للحدود وذلك
لان القانون الدولي لا يتيح للامم المتحده
ادخال مساعدات الى بلد دون موافقته في
سوريا يرفض نظام الاسد تماما دخول
المساعدات من هذه المعابر بحجه انتهاك
سياده البلاد وبسبب هذا الشرط اصدر مجلس
الامن القرار رقم
2672 للسماح بدخول المساعدات معبر باب
الهوى دون موافقه الاسد لكن القرار يحتاج
الى تجديد سنوي دخل معبر باب الهوى في قلب
نزاع دولي في مجلس الامن بين روسيا
الداعمه للنظام من جهه والدول الغربيه من
جهه اخرى
اذ رفعت روسيا الفيتو اكثر من مره لمنع
تجديد القرار اخرها في يوليو تموز
الامم المتحده نفسها متهمه بالتمه مع
النظام اذ تؤكد منظمه الدفاع المدني او ما
تعرف دوليا بالخوذ البيضاء وجود سند
قانوني لنقل المساعدات للسوريين دون
الحاجه الى تفويض دولي فمثلا بعد الزلزال
المدمر في السادس من شباط فبراير 2023
تاخرت المساعدات الامميه العاجله على
الشمال بضعه ايام ما تسبب في فقدان المزيد
من الارواح بحسب منظمه القوات البيضاء
تساءلت القوه البيضاء حينها عن سبب امتناع
الامم المتحده عن تفعيل اليه الاستجابه
للكوارث وارسال فريق الطوارئ الاممي الى
الشمال السوري رغم اتخاذها هذه الاجراءات
في مناطق النظام وجنوب تركيا
ويتاخرون على المساعدات اربعه ايام وبعدها
يقولون يجب ان تصمدوا كسوريين
[موسيقى]